we've got a couple woke Tik Tock videos
from Libs of Tik Tock
herself I am a non-binary middle school
special education teacher and only my
two pair of professionals know that I'm
nonbinary CU that's not like a
conversation I want to have with parents
and admin right now on the internet one
of my students said that I was a
beautiful King the other day and that
was just
so affirming gave me the gender Euphoria
have a good
day get your kids out of public school
fast it's that thing you experience as a
trans person when the person usually
like you know you're getting food or
you're at a store or whatever people
rather than be direct actually
transphobic to you they just kind of
ignore you and do the absolute bare
minimum going talk about that and how to
deal with it avoidant transphobia it's
uh it's a weird topic because it's it's
not the kind of thing that people really
think of when they think of transphobia
you're used to like the inyour face the
misgendering people being mean to you oh
God a lot gendering if you called this
girl a dude or a dude a girl someone
which is this this is a guy pretending
to be a girl right because what they're
really saying in those instances is you
don't exist to
them get over yourself these people if I
just put on some lipstick and went to
McDonald's that does sound pretty good
actually he you guys want to go to
McDonald's Conor was like here's the
lipstick let's go all right what's next
just started reading the Quran and I am
so excited about it people thought when
I first asked that I just wanted to read
it curiosity but I want to read it to I
started following somebody on social
media that teaches the Quran and hosts a
Quran book club for Muslims and
non-muslims so I'm really excited to
start going to that she was describing
the chapter of the bee and that just
blew my mind like the way that she
describes things the way that the Quran
describes things actually makes sense to
me also did you know that Allah is
beyond gender did you know that actually
scholars believe that there are two
qurans the Quran of Nature and the Quran
the actual book and did you know that
each chapter is named after a natural
phenomenon I just I don't know this
whole book is just blowing my mind and I
am so excited I got sticky notes so that
I could Mark out things that I was that
I was drawn to and uh I'm not even
through the first chapter and I already
have a bunch of sticky notes I'm
definitely going to have to buy more
tabs I'm honestly having a whole
Revolution with myself where the way
that I describe the universe and the
things that I believe in are actually
described in the Quran of believing in
Allah and I I've never thought that I
believed in God before and now I'm
really having a revolution of self of I
think I actually believe in God if
you've been curious I really recommend
it there are a lot of people who are
converting there's a lot of people who
are reading it I'm not saying I'm going
to convert I'm not saying that I
wouldn't um and I don't know I just I
know that this is exactly what I need
right now I just wanted to say thank you
and just point out how excited I
am I will donate
$110,000 to send her and him straight to
Gaza unfortunately for her or him or
fortunately I guess there were less tall
buildings to be thrown off of these days
uh but it should not surprise anybody
like joking aside the woke thing and
especially the radical Islam thing are
quite um totalitarian in their nature um
but this will not end well gaze for
Palestine is very different than
Palestine for
gays